these are the sounds of the mighty sperm
whale
there is clear structure in how these
animals communicate we just don't yet
know what they're saying our team of AI
Specialists roboticists linguists and
marine biologists aim to use the most
cutting-edge Technologies to make
contact with another species we're going
to put specific focus on the
interactions of mothers and calves
training our machine learning algorithms
to learn whale language from the bottom
up the raw audio and context data will
go through our machine learning engine
where it's going to be first sorted by
structure the Linguistics team will then
search for things like syntax and time
displacement and once we've really
mastered listening we're going to try
really carefully
to talk back even on the most simplistic
level and all the platforms that we
developed can be cross-applied to other
animals to elephants Birds primates
Dolphins essentially any animal